0.5 no 0.5 no 0.5 es 50% 0.5 en 60 minutos es esto 5% es esto le he puesto un 5% y ya deja correr
un poquito más y estamos en 49 se nos ha caído y al 50 nos ha caído pero a cambio fijaros que ha
hecho los 60 ahí está el tema si tú ves con 49 invalida hombre pero no ves que tienen unos
60 no está siendo saliendo simétrico no está ganando lo mismo que lo que pierde gana 3 80
pero es 26 porque porque esto salta menos al final no está actuando lo suficiente para para
para que eso tenga sentido tienes que igualar el retorno el riesgo y esto lo va a decir el
ratio 2 de acuerdo te lo va a decir el ratio 2 creo que ha quedado claro este punto no vale
entonces había alguna pregunta más pero me he comentado no sí creo que sí a ver aquí
habían algunas preguntas en discord vale hablaban sobre ahora voy repasando un poco y voy leyéndolos
como son públicas a lo que era aureli preguntaba sobre el vídeo de evaluación preliminar y hemos
hablado un poco de ello porque ya trato de aprovecharlo y hemos hablado un poco de ello
decía que que métrica usamos para decidir si pasa la evaluación o no en una evaluación preliminar
básicamente se trata que la idea tenga ventaja es esto que estamos viendo ahora un poco aureli
vale el que la idea tenga una cierta ventaja sin haber forzado mucho las cosas fíjate yo
te he puesto esto sencillo media tal y a partir de ahí podemos ver si trabajamos idealmente en
varios activos idealmente varios activos sobre todo en este tipo de sistemas tiene que ser en
varios activos en este tipo de sistemas tiene que ser en varios activos y ahora aquí esto lo tenía
antes en apple lo he hecho que lo iba a hacer de hecho y no lo he hecho vale le ponemos poner por
ejemplo google y tenemos que ver qué tal funciona lo ideal sería que en diversos activos nos mantuviera
un poquito tipo repito que estamos ahora bueno no sé si ahora estoy no ahora no ahora no espérate voy
a volver al set up anterior voy a volver al set up anterior voy a volver a anular la salida por tiempo
está está no lo he iniciado antes no lo he iniciado antes en la pausa y evidentemente me he equivocado
porque está sufriendo ya lo que no se ha escrito lo voy a igualar esto ahora cuando era 05 vamos
a poner 0 0 5 vale con don chan a 20 menos que a 20 le doy un poco más de margen ya porque si no
pero 10 pero yo creo que va a actuar ambos si si además cerca a todo por fuerza porque no
puede ser de otra manera en este caso no puede ser de otra manera aquí una de las cosas que haremos
es darle margen a las entradas de decir no permitirle esto es una cosa de momento la he comentado
en el código porque no quería ensuciar el código lo he comentado vale entonces ahora que yo por
ejemplo tengo google esto por ejemplo maestro lo podría mirar en varios en una cesta de acciones
no sé si me va a dar tiempo a hacerlo más o menos rápido a ver vamos a intentarlo como
se llama esto actuar acciones venga vamos a poner este para acciones acciones a de estrategia
problemas que esto está tan saturado que va a sufrir esto se nos se nos se nos va
se llama así se llama curso se llama curso fuera un problema muy grande es que las acciones
le vamos a meter menos años a serlo solucionado que no me va a afectar me va a frenar mucho
vamos con esto more management 100% nominal
limite de acciones símbolis venga que te metemos el nasdaq
vamos a ver el nasdaq 100 vamos con todo las acciones y
empezamos con hoy está avisando no no no diremos que no avisa no
diremos que no avisa en el nuevo porfolio por folio apolo no por folio sistema de
estructura n7 n100 vamos con el porfolio settings me da igual a de strategy group
estima futura actes por folio en un número esto vamos con 10.000 dólares hasta ayer
y le vamos a meter 10 años a pero claro mali management 10 no mali management 0 1
porque vamos con 100 acciones venga ahí vamos lo dejamos ahí trabajando vale sí sí no no es
que ya pensaba hacer esto es lo que decía aquí ahora lo voy a mirar directamente en
muchas acciones a la vez vale quería hacerlo quería hacerlo así no sé ni cómo lo dejó
pero 505 vale y salir en 10 barras de puesto bueno bueno es igual para evaluar la entrada
no me sirve debería verlo pero ahora lo hago otra vez que va que va rápido aquí lo tenemos
aquí podemos ver todas las cestitas de acciones aquí todo el índice vemos algunas cosas rojas
tenemos bastante verde en general verde y podemos ver el gráfico de todas y nos rompe la curva
tremendamente dramática un gigantesco y esto es por acción ahí lo vemos vale bueno hay bastantes
perdedoras algunas ganadoras hay un poco de todo lo pasa que la idea que llevaba no era esta sino
ésta que lo voy a hacer ahora y hacer lo mismo que habíamos hecho antes es decir meterle aquí
20 esto creo que no 0 10 0 10 aquí meterle pues 500 para que no actuará y aquí pues lo voy a
dejar preguntas tengo algunas de aquí o sigo de las que tenía pendientes a ver todo cuando digo
que es una vez de ahora es que de verdad no nos paremos en esta hora que ya llegaremos ya llegaremos
llegaremos es decir una vez ya porque porque la curva era bastante lamentable tenía por el factor
bastante bajo para acciones en diarias era no insisto ya lo comentaste no estoy haciendo hoy
un sistema de uso operable antes hemos explicado los datos y ahora estaba simplemente introduciendo
el primer paso de un sistema acordaros los que espero que muchos es la primera parte de la teoría
la mayoría habéis hecho la primera parte de la teoría hablamos de perfiles y luego el desarrollo
hablamos de setups de entrada filtros etcétera simplemente he planteado un setup de entrada es
lo que hecho de acuerdo simplemente eso he planteado un setup de entrada que es un dolce y
aparte de ahí le he puesto un stop y un tp simétrico porque tengo que cerrar la operación
acordaros que para evaluar entradas hay que hacer algo yo le he puesto un tp simétrico y le he puesto
una salida temporal pero la he anulado poniéndole 500 bajas de acuerdo entonces la he anulado para
que para que me saliera obligatoriamente por esto ptp y ahora que he hecho hecho eso mismo que habéis
hecho en tres session pero lo he aplicado a todo el nasdaq cien porque bueno pues porque así puedo
ver muchas acciones así puedo ver muchas acciones vale entonces aquí veis cada barrita esto es una
acción veis que hay muchas ganadoras y hay muchas peleadoras entonces al final en el sumario veo que
gana 208 mil veo que tiene un profit factor de 1.04 que es bajísimo fijaros que tiene un average
win de solo 0.74 y tiene un momentito que no veo ahora lo que busco aquí por ventaja de acierto
es el 58% esto es lo que quería quería ver es justito porque tiene un win loss bastante bajo
pero que no protege de acierto superior al 50% que es lo que ahora mirábamos de manera rápida
aquí simplemente simplemente evaluaba eso nada más pensar que esto no está ni bien dimensionado
vale no está ni bien y mencionado y aquí lo expuesto veis 600% realmente está totalmente
solo expuesto porque tenía que haberle puesto no 0.10 y no 0.01 pero bueno voy a hacerlo por
por tercera vez por tercera vez para conseguir la información que quiero 20 es por ciento es
por ciento 500 repito que trato sólo de evaluar la entrada aquí le he puesto 0.10 tiene que haberle
puesto 0.001 no eso es 10% 0.001 tengo que ponerle simplemente quiero ver si me da más de un 50%
mirado en todas las acciones en las acciones en los últimos 10 años simple o sea estoy haciendo
una evaluación preliminar si más una evaluación preliminar acordaros en las fases sencillita de
simplemente la entrada a tonchan en todas las acciones del nasa que si veo que ahí tiene algún
sentido seguir este camino nada más y que me fijo básicamente que engane dinero vale ahora que
gané dinero y que como he puesto simétricos esto pítepe que tengan más de un 50% de acierto
bueno quizá ahora me he bajado quizá ahora me he pasado en la exposición no era 0.1 pero gana
10 dólares ahora me he pasado un 0 de verdad estoy estoy hoy me pasa a ver déjame ver lo que
he hecho a ver lo que he hecho le he puesto 0.10 20 y vale 0.001 pero antes cuanto había puesto antes
0.10 era un 0 solo era un 0 era 0.006 venga a la 14a va la vencida la 14a va la vencida volvemos
con el tranchón de 20 0 10 0 10 y 500 barros decir voy a compro en ruptura de canal de 20
stop simétrico 10 0 10 y aquí 0.01 verdad alberto 1% 1% 1% en cada acción que de un poquito por
debajo del 100% esto es simplemente evaluación preliminar nada más vale es decir al final los
ratios que miramos en aquí de evaluación preliminar no son simplemente es esto es que
tenga un porcentaje de aciertos ahora superiores 50 y que tenga ganancias positivas poco más en
este punto poco más en este punto poco más bueno esto ya empieza ahora a tener más sentido ya
empieza a tener más sentido vale ya lo hemos dimensionado correctamente empieza a tener un
poco más de sentido al final dimensionar las cosas bien como visteis en la práctica de
esto es muy curioso es ahora estoy 60 50 por ciento expuesto todavía está poco expuesto pero
bueno pero ya ya lo hemos expuesto un poco más ya lo hemos expuesto un poco más pero es que
estará un compuesto 5 anualizado poco pero tenemos una veras muy casi del 1 y un porcentaje de
aciertos del 59 casi estoy al uno es decir parece que hay ventaja en la entrada parece que hay
ventaja en la entrada en una evaluación preliminar lo que vamos a decir es eso no vamos a decir nada
más es decir que parece que hay ventaja nada más ya ya veremos si a partir de ahí hacemos algo lo
mejor después lo trabajamos nosotros una porquería pero ahora mismo vemos que el sistema ganado de
dinero anualizan 5 por ciento expuesto 60 50 por ciento es decir prácticamente un 10 por ciento
anualizado al 100 por ciento exposición tiene un average win loss de 0 97 decir casi 1 y da un
profitable de 59 por ciento es decir acierta 6 de cada 10 operaciones en todas en todas las
acciones es decir estos son 3500 trades vale en todas las acciones el nasa 100 en muchas
pierde pero muchas gana muchas pierde y en muchas gana y entonces eso es lo que yo ahora mismo quiero
simplemente le he puesto un stop simétrico no he optimizado nada le he puesto un don chan de 20
barras por defecto no he tocado nada y no he dejado ni salir por tiempo porque le he obligado
a salir por esto ptp bienvenidos que veo que puede haber cierta ventaja en un don chan en
diario en acciones americanas porque lo he probado en 100 acciones vale eso es un poco una evaluación
preliminar típica vale entonces enlazo con las preguntas sé que esto es lo que me preguntaba
también ligado con lo que había preguntado también aureli y había preguntado también ante
ante igualmente alejandro también que todo esto va todo en conexión vale y sigo sigo con las con
las preguntas se preguntaba los datos de forex esto ya te contestó alberto pero bueno como
antes comentaba los datos de forex cada broker el mercado tiene los suyos eso es así eso te
dice es como los dvds no no tienen que ser iguales luego comentaba sobre el vídeo 577 que
también liga un poquito con esto que hemos visto hoy comentaba que se yo comentaba en la teoría
que para sistemas con poco ningún parámetro el proceso finalizaría en el forwar testing
a bajar de pocos parámetros el paseo de la evaluación preliminar al forwar testing se
hace el paso de la optimización clásica ni la wall forwar es correcta esta afirmación bueno
esto lo vamos a ir viendo mucho un poco ya has visto por donde van los tiros hoy yo lo que puedo
hacer es probar el sistema en muchas acciones por ejemplo si no puedo sacarlo en una sola acción
al mejor lo puedo probar en muchas puede ser un camino puede ser un camino pero vamos a intentar
hacerlo porque cuando hablamos de wall forwar hablamos que habían dos había el cláster vale
y dentro del cláster estaba el anchole y no en anchole de acuerdo yo puedo usar anchole y
entonces ahí gano muestra entonces hay distintas maneras distintas maneras también como no habíamos
todo esto ya lo comenté un poco pero comentaré los detractores es decir no me gusta es un debate
que me resulta interesante y me gusta abordarlo no creéis que hay gente que
más gente que a mí me merece todo mi respeto y admiración es decir no no es no es algo no es algo
que sea la biblia de acuerdo es decir todo lo que tiene que ver con la manipulación de datos
siempre hay siempre hay debate siempre hay debate no se ponen de acuerdo con los datos
cobit imaginaros que con los mismos datos hay gente que defiende que las vacunas funcionan
si es difícil analizar datos con los mismos datos con los mismos datos o sea porque intervienen
sesgos la manipulación y ahí hay como ya he dicho muchas veces es fácil hacerse trampas al
solitario con la manipulación de datos es muy fácil es muy fácil entonces por eso digo que y
luego también hay un factor de gusto cuidado pero pero bueno eso ya en este tema debería ser menos
importante sigo y él en la onda en este dice si es correcto esto que no se puede hacer well
forward or forward testing sería válido efectuar la metodología de fiction el antiguo el forro para
estos casos se mostrará un ejemplo de la metodología de la metodología braque bueno podemos verlo
podemos ver alguna algún ejemplo con él con el braque es que el braque en mi opinión tiene tiene
mucho de como te lo diría yo como tiene mucho estética o sea es que no me sale la palabra ahora
es que braque si tú lo piensas al final aureli que entiendo que se me pregunta es que has leído
sobre sobre él no aparte de lo que lo que explique yo de hecho el libro de fiction es recomendable
al final simplemente lo que hace es una optimización completa de acuerdo una tradición completa
acordaros cuando hemos hecho nosotros tema de perfil que hicimos incluso hablamos de 50 a 50
hablamos cortar por delante cortar por detrás es algo bastante parecido a esto si lo piensas es
algo bastante parecido no es exactamente igual porque nosotros lo que hacemos es un trozo en
sample y dejamos uno fuera y luego lo hacemos por otro lado es lo que haces toda la optimización
excluye una parte post optimización y optimiza y no pero olvídate del orden de las cosas de acuerdo
esa segunda optimización que hace él es nuestra primera in sample voy a intentar cuidado voy a
intentar coger el lápiz espera aquí si yo despejo ahora todo se me queda todo azul creo no claro se
me queda todo azul y a igual yo puedo pintar no a ver esto sería ver pintar o no quito el tiempo
aquí el tiempo y pinto tremendo lo que acabo de descubrir tengo una pizarra aquí de lujo vale
entonces vamos a intentar optimización esto es en la optimización clásica enseñamos vamos a suponer
que esto es 75 por ciento y que esto es 25 por ciento esto es con ratón en tener bastante
verito a medias a ver venga mi hija escriben mucho mejor que esto bueno no mi hija ahora claro ya
me dijo con tres años ya escribió mejor que esto a ver esto sería la normal vale rayita
muy bien vale que hace braque te dice haces esta optimización que le llama pilt vale te dice quita
una parte y le llamo revil y compara esto con esto vale lo que yo te estoy diciendo es que el
revil es esto el revil es esto no no es min sam pero es revil pero se me entiende y él me
dice que compara todo esto con todo esto porque porque así dice es verdad eso tiene mayor
significación vale esto dice que tiene muy poca significación y ya dice que lo del software es
ciencia ficción porque dice que todos los trocitos de cortar así no hay ningún sentido porque cortar
así sí sí sí es verdad al final también luego hay otros autores que defienden prado lo defienden
que veáis es que metes mucho sesgo ahí yo creo que con él con el cláster no es cierto que haya
que haya sesgo pienso de verdad pero es verdad que hay otras metodologías que también son
interesantes son muy interesantes pero mutación de periodos modificación del periodo de barras y
es que hay mil maneras de validar lo que ocurre es que yo creo firmemente que está valida que hay
otras que validan seguro por lo que sí entonces al final el revil que te quiero decir os saldrá
que al final por todo ahora vale tiene bastante de no sé al final en todos sus ejemplos que pone es
una muestra gigantesca él al final construye una muestra enorme con un montón de operaciones y
comparando esto con esto te dice pues ya estás es que es verdad o sea es que yo si hago esta
optimización vamos a suponer tengo un único parámetro y esto tiene 5.000 operaciones
un único parámetro distrio acordaros las cosas que dijimos distribución de trade uniforme bla bla
bla es que no hace falta que hagas nada aquí para operar me explico si tú conseyes una distribución
uniforme es 5.000 operaciones me explico es que no te hace falta ni autosap o sea al final es todo es
todo una una un sitio común y una coherencia es decir al final si tú consigues suficiente
significación estadística además con simplicidad con idea robusta y con todo aquello insisto que
os comenté ahora lo estoy buscando en aquella diapositiva donde resumo donde estás resumo
que es una estrategia robusta donde estás es que es esta es esta tampoco no es antes de aquí es
antes de aquí es que tengo diapositivas para un carro esta es no tampoco es esta ya no queda
muchas que se parezcan a esta debe ser esta esta si es vale espera que quito el dibujito vale si
yo tengo una distribución uniforme de operaciones si yo tengo una distribución uniforme de los
trates y de su beneficio tengo un mapa estable vale con ya se entiende no encima encima a eso ya
para acabarle siempre con 5.000 trates ni esta hace falta y número significativo de tres como te decía
y muestra representativa y una curva estable es que esto es robusto esto es muy probablemente
robusto esto es muy probablemente robusto con brak sin brak y hasta single folder probablemente
ahora el tema es dónde está esa barrera y que al final siempre mayor seguridad es mejor o sea
dónde está esta barrera este número este número que ya dices oyes que me da igual todo es claro
ahí es donde entra mucho brak entonces si yo meto yo te digo meto sistemas de este tipo y luego
te digo te digo el vamos a hacer un sisma inverso y le ponemos nombre esto nos reíamos nosotros aquí
porque todos los grandes otros que hacen cursos ponen nombre nos reíamos le tenemos que poner
un nombre sabes porque es que es esto sacas un libro y le tienes que poner un nombre a tu historia
y al final todas son más o menos la misma con su toque pero pues se pone el nombre porque es así
es verdad está bien no a nivel de bar que entonces tú le pones un nombre y sacas un libro y lo vendes
y hasta ahí te haces milenario todo así bueno pues nosotros no le hemos puesto nombre no somos
bolos en marketing como ya hemos dicho muchas veces no le hemos puesto nombre a nada vale entonces
esto era un poco lo de que lo que te explicó sobre sobre brak entonces sí que se puede hacer y al
final si tú haces brak y tienes una muestra muy tal tienes esto que te he enseñado ahora
probablemente te saldrá bien te funcionará y sin brak también y sin brak también te
funcionará entonces ya está vale qué más me preguntabas también me preguntabas también
vale ya estaba esto para hablar del porfolio si hablabas de que había comentado del
tratamiento holístico del porfolio es decir como un como un conjunto si tendría sentido un
planteamiento de destino tp loco para el porfolio cerrando todas las posiciones en el caso de llegar
a stp global independientemente de cada una de las unidades que forman sistemas tuvieran positivas
o negativas en el instante en que el global llegara al objetivo de ser esto cierto como se puede
evaluar esta es muy buena pregunta aureli y si tiene sentido nosotros hoy en día no lo hacemos
pero tiene totalmente el sentido esto tiene sentido si si si esto es correcto y hay muchos
autores que lo hacen de acuerdo es decir stop o stop y tp de porfolio si si si totalmente esto
tiene tiene sentido como lo evaluas bueno pues con un software que lo valúan no tiene más maestro lo
puede hacer msa ahora mismo creo que también cual analiza lo hace creo simplemente con una regla
de código con una regla del código que lo haga si no tiene no tiene mayor historia en
ese lenguaje puede porque hay alguna librería de maestro además que maestro se hace y por folio
trader te esto que es seguro que también los software de porfolio suelen permitirlo ya código
vía interface pero sí sí sí tiene sentido y tiene sentido y se puede evaluar por si
cualquier otra cosa vale luego carlos apuntaba sobre los regímenes de mercado irá saliendo irá
saliendo si tenemos algún paper que recomienden para estudiar los distintos regímenes por ahora
mismo sí que hay seguro que tengo alguno que aseguro que tengo alguno apúntate está alberto
de buscar papers de regimenes de mercado porque estoy prácticamente seguro de tener alguno en
la documentación vale entonces hay bastante tema vale yo te digo una cosa una cosa nosotros
hemos estado mucho tiempo sin filtrar regímenes de mercado ahora lo estamos empezando a hacer
pero no porque no supiéramos lo lo hubiéramos evaluado antes porque lo que digo siempre lo
bueno pero siempre lo que no sé ahora mismo carlos si habías hecho la teoría ya no cuánto etcétera
al final este tipo de implementaciones del sistema de regímenes se meten vía filtro siempre vía
filtro si tú tienes imagínate ese sistema sencillo que hemos visto antes vale y yo veo que pues no va
bien como casi ninguno en volatilidad y yo meto un filtro de volatilidad la mayoría de filtros
de este tipo van por volatilidad está saturadísimo el equipo ya una cosa de
los van por por vía vía volatilidad pero pueden haber otros entonces pues el tenencial entonces
al final no deja de ser un filtro no deja de ser una regla más no deja de ser una posible sobre
utilización más entonces ahí es donde siempre tienes la duda de que tú en mediante ese filtro
vas a eliminar trades imagínate que yo tengo 800 trades y mi filtro me quita 300 trades y me quedo
con 500 trades he mejorado el sistema pero he perdido significación estadística ahí está
mejora lo suficiente bueno es ese es el debate habrá veces que sí habrá veces que no
a veces que sí habrá veces que y yo es verdad que tengo bastante tendencia a eso incluso alguna vez
te diría demasiado en determinados momentos creo que hasta lo he llevado demasiado lejos creo y
puedo haberme equivocado en haberlo hecho en ese aspecto en concreto es decir de ser demasiado
persistente en en no querer filtrar demasiado porque al final filtrar es una de las maneras
más fáciles sobre utilizar carlos porque tú estás justamente eliminando lo malo tienes o sea
tú tienes un setup como esto es sencillo que yo te he enseñado ahora y luego digo mira o sea le
quito por la volatilidad le quito unas cuantas operaciones venga ahora por la tendencia tienes
la tentación de empezar a filtrar a filtrar filtrar y te queda un back test pero guapo guapo
guapo pero una cosa impecable ahora luego resulta que el sistema es real pues va mucho
peor que se esperaba para los dos sistemas suelen ir bastante línea con lo esperado y en
desviaciones bastante cuando hay desviaciones que las ha habido es público hemos explicado todo lo
que nos ha pasado aunque a pesar después de todos los problemas que hemos tenido hemos batido
nuestro mensaje en sí o no pero pero bueno aún así han habido errores y ha habido cosas hay cosas
que me juzgan pero lo que lo que digo de los filtros entonces al final no sé siempre siempre
ese debate siempre esa duda y siempre te quedas con filtros y filtros no los filtros se pueden
usar no no no que criminalizarlos de entrada pero pero prudencia prudencia ante ellos porque al
final filtrar filtrar mucho es un camino directo al overfit es un camino directo al overfit hay
que filtrar con mucha prudencia en caso de dudas no filtras eso te lo digo en caso de dudas no filtres
vale alejandro yo creo que ya ha quedado claro todo el tema de alejandro y luego hablaba
senen garcía sobre el multidata bueno el multidata haremos también multidata
comentaba él le comentaba que había hecho un backtest en multidata que ha intentado crear una
estrategia con con acciones donde ha añadido filtro que el sp 500 estuviera por encima de
una media vale necesita dos datas y tenía problemas con el tema de los datos bueno esto
creo que ya tenemos contestado directamente allí bueno decías que no entendías mucho esto hombre
tiene su lógica porque al final si las bases de datos no se alinean igual cuesta de tomar pero
bueno al principio ya te lo hemos solucionado haremos estrategias de los datos este que usas
tú es una estrategia bastante común de filtro es decir usar una acción de filtrar que en ese
otro bueno aplica lo que he dicho ahora aplica totalmente lo que lo que he dicho ahora totalmente
lo que he dicho ahora filtrar puede ser pero prudencia con ello porque puede ser que te salga
que le salga mal me queda alguna pregunta por ahí el aberto jose dolet dices vale dice que sobre los
filtros en un vídeo comentaba que cuando añades un filtro tiene que filtrar bastantes para que
no sobreteneces puede ser bueno la más que filtrar tiene que las dos cosas y al final cualquier
regla que tú evaluas jose tiene que tener implicación fíjate fíjate aquí a ver si esto
me va ahora cuando yo te decía en el sistema se tendencia ni carga ya es que ni carga que
te decía he bajado el stop y el tp para que actuara más porque porque si yo implemento
una regla que casi no actúa no la estoy evaluando estoy engañando me explico decimos 30 30 por
por por grado de libertad si dijimos un poco de 30 50 pero claro que actúe si yo pongo un tp que
pasa dos veces evaluado no está que puede puedes usarlo o no pero no está evaluado estadísticamente
los dos tenemos alguna en no y ese algunas estrategias de salida que tiene una corrección
muy baja pero pero bueno yo la quiero yo la puedo poner por ejemplo hablaba antes de creo que la
orel y no recuerdo de un tp o un stop en el porfolio a lo mejor no actúa nunca pero es igual yo quiero
por ejemplo que nunca en un mes pueda perder más de tanto pues pues punto pues yo lo pongo ya está
si pierde lo cierro o es que no sabrán ya bueno pero yo no puedo no puedo o no quiero perder más
de un 5 por ciento si llego a esa perdida cierro el mes por ejemplo después de haber relas que no
que sean por gestión por requisitos de riesgo del regulador o requisitos de riesgo tuyos por lo que
sea te despasan por encima de acuerdo de la evaluación no pero pero en términos generales
hablamos de reglas del sistema no de gestión monetaria que eso va a parte
filtro como esto que comentas si que debe estar evaluado por un mínimo de operaciones que las
respalden y luego lo que te decía que se queden en el sistema también respalden es decir las dos
cosas el filtro tiene que estar respaldado y el sistema antes del filtro y post filtro se tiene
que quedar respaldado por una suficiente muestra que me dé significación estadística así que sí
si las cosas es sí vale buen color para cegarnos antonio pues nada te pondré fosforito próximo
día te pongo fosforito y en vez de fondo azul fondo negro aún va a ser más más pero vale
a ver me marco aquí bueno al principio por lo que yo veo aquí marcado está todo respondido no
vale pues decirme si alguna cosita más recordar vuelve a recordar el disco da dos cosas que
recuerdo vale dos cosas que recuerdo una la clase ya no va a ir con el link que visteis vale la
vamos a subir ya si no hay problemas hoy mismo a la plataforma de learning ya está todo preparado
la primera ya está ahí ya está ahí y la segunda va a estar la hora cuando acabemos de la clase se
procesa y se sube el segundo a partir de en el mismo sitio que está la teoría así ya no
tienen dos sitios además hay mucha gente que todavía no acabó la teoría pues está
la teoría y debajo las prácticas vale ese por un lado y luego recuerdo sigo recordando el
disco por lo que podéis ahí preguntar está bien a gente que a veces participa se pregunta
entre ellas se ayuda y parece me parece perfecto para eso está un poquito y podéis entrar
entre vosotros y por mi parte nada más si cualquier otra pregunta repito la puedes poner el disco
lo de las preguntas en la plataforma de learning ya creo que me lo deshabilitaron porque es que iba
fatal entonces dijo pues quítalo entonces digo preguntas al disco y hasta la semana que viene
seguiremos con él partiendo este sistema ya tengo alguno otro más preparado que está por aquí pero
bueno seguiremos con seguiremos con éste y iremos creciendo encima de él hablando todo esto que
hemos hablado ahora y que hemos visto un poquito preliminar pues lo que vimos en el curso iremos
haciendo los siguientes pasos con esta sistema de don chan a ver si conseguimos alguna cosita con él
a ver si conseguimos alguna cosita con él que yo confío que sí pero ya veremos porque es una idea
que hasta he operado es decir que entiendo que tiene que salir pero que de verdad que lo hemos
empezado a hacer o sea que no tiene le hemos empezado hecha de cero en el código de acuerdo
así que nada más amigos a ver si conseguimos llegar a polo no bueno oye quién sabe quién sabe
quién sabe yo ya lo comenté antonio la clase se pasada y créeme que es 100% verdad en el curso
vamos a hacer cosas que vamos a aprovechar nosotros 100% porque son muchas horas como para dejarlas
perder al final voy a voy a aprovecharlas lógicamente no todas porque serán cosas ya
media que avancemos pero nosotros vamos a hacer cosas en el curso 100% que luego yo aprovecharé
así que si las podemos aprovechar nosotros también vosotros eso está clarísimo de acuerdo pues nada
más hasta aquí la segunda clase os veo el lunes que viene chao